hello everyone and welcome to another
crazy game from the Grantchester it's
again from the penultimate round of the
Blitz section Magnus Carlsen versus
Roush Manhattan Island like I said
really a crazy game with chances on both
sides so without further ado let's just
check out the game and like we said
after we're gonna check out the
standings and you know who won some
rating who lost some rating and whatnot
so a Magnus with the white pieces opens
with b4 we have Knight to f6 by Anand
Knight to f3 and d5 now and here Bishop
to f4 Magnus goes for the London system
we have e 6 preparing to develop the
dark square Bishop e3 and Bishop to d6
and here just Knight B to d2 it's often
in the London system that you will not
go back up to g3 you don't care about
doubling your f1 because you want the de
5 square so Bishop captures with it
captures like being the head against
Magnus in the previous game and well you
saw how that went
Queen to d6 attacking the bf4 pawn and
now g3 defends a while preparing to be
in here to the light square bishop we
have b6 under does the same and c3 and
here we have castles we have Bishop to
d3 and now Bishop to a6 Bishop captures
on a6 with Knight captures on a6 and
Queen e2 going after the night here
night the b8 and here is a very
interesting moment because Anand already
had this position in last year in Leuven
where a four was played he had it
against Nakamura and the Nakamura played
a four in this position on the wounded
game and it's hard to say if Magnus
knows this game or not but the Magnus
deviates here with Knight to e5 it's a
it's a different move than one Nakamura
played and it is a new move in the
position and also it is the strongest
move recommended by the engine so it's
hard to say if Magnus knows the game
anand versus nakamura but well magnus
did show in an interview we checked out
of you about shocker shot a few videos
ago that he knows a lot of
on ins games by heart so Knight to e5 we
have c5 by Anand now striking in the
center and now
df3 this night takes it takes its place
nice to e4 now with strong control of
ee5 you also have a hole on e4 so on and
uses it for his night
we have castles by Magnus in the now f6
again this is one of the positions where
it's okay to push up six with nice to g4
and you don't have to worry about losing
your night since you still have the e3
squared to go to so here on earth
continuous development the knight to c6
d captures on c5 b captures in the rook
a to d1 now lining up the rook with the
queen preparing to push c4 we have F 5
by aren't bringing the knight back to e5
and now rook a to b8 putting pressure on
the b2 pawn if the Queen moves with c4
by Magnus and now you could go for d4
it's definitely possible creates a
passed pawn but then you get Knight
capture screen captures and this guy
comes to e5 and well it's a it's a bit
of a trade-off sure it's possible for
black but underweight with the pushing
of the D pawn he goes Knight captures on
e5 first night CalPERS on e5 and now
rook F to d8 with rook after a one by
Magnus and Queen to a6 now saying okay
if you capture we can trade Queens but
also I'm just attacking your a to pawn
so here are Magnus first goes f3 kicks
away the knight Knight to f6 and now
just be three defense both both c4 and
a2 we have rugby to see it now and now
rook the c1 if the position opens up you
want your look opposing your opponent's
rook and now Arnold pushes d4 and
creates a very strong past deep on
Knight the d3 now by Magnus and rook to
d6 now as the e6 pawn will is under
attack you do have to defend it we have
rook to c2 now adding another defender
38 to pawn now you can move the Queen
and Knight to d7 now we have Queen - G -
and here comes Queen to b6 now preparing
to bring the Queen back into the game
and also to push a5 a4 we have rook c2e2
doubling up on the e-file now now again
this is pressured if if you're not
careful you might lose it a5 by black
and here look the beat you now just in
case a nun pushes
or you can just answer would be for if
captures you can just capture attack the
Queen you guard the c4 pawn everything
is nicely protected so here we have
looked back to be it by Anand and the
Queen back to d2 by Magnus we have Queen
to c7 and then out comes Queen to d1 we
have h6 making some room for the king
and now rook beat the e2 again doubling
up on the e-file threatening to win d6
pawn and Queen to b6 so a lot of back
and forth trying to find each other's
weaknesses and you know try to make the
other guy lose as much time as possible
since this is a blitz game with eight
four by Magnus and now a four by Anand
so Magnus brings drew back to be 2 now a
cat person b3 a capture son b3 and queen
to a7 now preparing rook to a6 and rook
to a2 we have kicked the h2 by Magnus
and now rook to a 6 so of course Magnus
doesn't want to allow troop to a 2 we
have Queen that e 2 now guarding da 2
squared twice and not rook a to b6
threatening to just win this guy here
and you don't have to worry about it yet
because Queen captures and e6 would be
just too strong so guarding the pawn
again with Queen d1 or something like
that or night c1 would just be a waste
of time so here Magnus continues with
the g4 now like I said capturing here
allowing the loss of the e6 pawn is just
game over for black after the King moves
you're gonna go captures captures and
now it's just over check and after the
King moves and now Queen to f7 and there
is no good defense against Queen to f5
check followed by rook to e8 e8
so after g4 with F captures and g4 f
captures energy for and now Queen to c7
lining up the Queen with the King here
but now g5 by Magnus he really wants to
open up a defiles a leading to islands
king with H captors and g5 h captors and
g5 and now we have a 5 a very nice
positional pawn sacrifice which will
allow on and we'll get the rook into the
game also you have ideas of night f8
which control both ecigs and g6 so here
at Magnus captures at F captors only 5
and now rook the e6 night the f8 right
away
and might have been better but okay look
the e6 Anand wants to get the other rock
over here and the reclaim his spawn
we have 24 by Magnus now you can go
Queen to d5 to pin the rook and now
comes well just a rugby t8 now
threatening to win back the e5 pawn
queen to d5 now pinning the rook and now
comes Knights to b6 attacking the Queen
pushing the Queen back here we have
Queen captures on c5 Magnus grabs
another pawn and here
Anand should probably trade Queens with
Queen captures Knight captures and just
grab this guy here rook captures rook
captures and after a 93 attacking the
rook now you should go back with rook to
e3 you could grab the point equalizing
material but then white still connected
past points might be too much for you to
handle
so here it's a really tricky idea if
Anand would would enjoy such such an end
game against Magnus probably not so here
Anand played Queen to d8 but now
okay the thread is to just pick up the
the g5 point but now Magnus defends with
rook the g2 it is the strongest move in
the position problem is if ruk g1 then
black has a tricky defense after 97
attacks the Queen and the e5 pawn Queen
captures on d4 and now Queen c7 you will
now reclaim your pawn and a cross and
skiing is wide open here so here rope
the g2 is much better than the other
were coming to g1 because now the same
idea doesn't work if Knight d7 you
simply don't capture but clay Queen to
d5 and now it's problematic the rook is
pinned so you're gonna have to add
another attacker but now Knight to f4
will just win material you lose you lose
the exchange here so after rogue g2 we
have looked the f8 by Anand and now
comes Queen to b5 by Magnus really
really a wild position both of them very
low on time Magnus much lower on time
and here I don't you just go for a look
at five and rook captures on g5 it is
the best he has in the position but he
prefers rook to f3 instead now okay it
adds an attack to the night here and
here Magnus has to be very careful the
the best course of action for Magnus is
c5 it's just
the best because here if rook captures
on d3 it's not a problem
the Queen now guards it so obviously
impossible
so c5 you guard the knight and also you
start advancing your passport this is
the best idea but Magnus here play
Knight to c5 which makes sense you get
out of the way you add additional
protection to the b3 point you attack
the e6 rook but this move loses the game
for Magnus so feel free to pause the
video and try to find the winning move
for Anand while I give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who are able to
do it that is just really impressive
it's not an easy move to find well it is
well now that I've told you maybe it may
be fun but all of the complications that
lead after that move really crazy stuff
so for those of you who found the
congratulations and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
rook the h6 check now it's really really
ugly point is that if the rook is
captured Queen h4 just wins the game
King king g1 now you pick up the rook
with check King h2 now you pick up the
e5 pawn with check King g1 now Queen e3
check and now you're in the meeting that
King h1 luggage 3 check you're gonna go
back you have to block rook h2 now Queen
e1 check King g2 and now just look the
g3 is mate so after this rook h6 check
you will not be able to pick up the rook
most likely white on and well if you
don't pick up the rook King to g1 the
the only move that wins here now after
King's you want is d3 because now again
you don't care about the rock you don't
care about anything Queen to death for
check is just too big of a threat now
Yugi captures and h6 you're gonna have
Queen to d4 check and again your your
just again you have to go to the H file
and again you have Queen to h4 check and
you repeat the mating sequence that
we've already seen only the Queen
doesn't reach f h4 via the this diagonal
but VAR d 4 and D for to h4 so quite
similar but the only thing white has
after d3 it's not capturing the rook but
rather Knight captures here but it's a
it's too ugly to even analyze I'm just
showing it because it's super
interesting and now Queen captures now
you don't have Queen D for check because
Knight can
block so Queen captures and III has to
be played but now Queen e8 check rook
the f8 you don't have time to allow
Queen d4 so you have to give up the
Queen King captures and tau G captures
on h6g captures are now II 6 and here
Magnus would have two rooks against the
Queen and the night he would have to
struggle really hard to survive this but
most likely it would end in a win for
for Anand
so after 95 rook to h6 winning for Anand
but Anand plays rook to g6 instead he
wants to go after the g5 pawn which he
should have done two moves ago but you
know it's blitz it's really crazy and
here Magnus has to go Knight here it's
really important because it guards the
g5 phone also the g3 square but Magnus
pushes East 6 and again he gives Anand a
winning position now on and just has to
go for the g5 pawn and after rook
captures
it's just winning whatever you do for
example if East 7 just Queen d6 now
again it's game over
kingi one rook captures Queen captures
King captures and Queen to g3 check King
h1 again you're in the mating net check
kim jiwon ruby is Richard here and this
will just deliver mate so after East six
Magnus again blunders mate but Anand
again doesn't find it first he goes
Queen to d6 check King to g1 and now he
captures it but now it's different
because now that the queen is on d6 it
no longer works yes you are threatening
to capture and queen g3 like we've shown
but now 94 is just deadly this is what
calls him plate and it was in this
position and more 51 that Anand resigned
the game because now the Queen is under
attack the rook is under attack you
don't have characters followed by Queen
g3 as the night covers the g3 square as
well so there is not nothing more to be
played here you could try rook captures
King captures and quinta f8 you might
try this or Queen to f4 because your
Queen and the rook are under attack so
you might try Queen f4 but then you get
Queen to d8 with check Queen to f8 now
you just trade captures rook captures so
you save the rook but e 7 and wherever
the road goes 96 and you control the
queening square it's
so after kink actress Angie - you might
try instead of queena for Quinta f-8 but
now just east 7 is very strong and now
you hear I have to pick this up to lose
the rook or you will get another Queen
on the board so a really incredible
stuff after Knight to e4 after Magnus
Magnus give vichy two chances to punish
him that rook h6 and rogue g5 but it's
blue it's you know anything can happen
so Indian Magnus again emerges
victorious so just so I don't forget
here we prepared some very nice photos
courtesy of Leonard Otis these are the
three gentleman that qualified for the
finals of the Grantchester they will be
playing in London in the London Chest
classic Magnus Levin and Bing and they
will be joined by Maxime for Sheila
graph Anand missed qualifying for the
for the London chess classic by less
than one Grantchester point I believe
it's 0.8 points so a tough break for him
if if he I don't know I it's like if he
won I don't know maybe one more game I
don't know how it goes but he was
extremely close to qualifying for London
so a tough break for Anand and we do
have the standings of the well
Grantchester of the tata still rapid and
blitz tournament here it is
Magnus wins and not only does Magnus
wounded with 27 out of 36 this is the
world record now for the grand Chester
so far it's been 26 26 and a half out of
36 which Magnus achieved in in Abidjan
in Cote d'Ivoire rapid in blitz
tournament but here he breaks his own
record by a half a point and the record
before that was also Magnus I believe in
Leuven in in I don't know 2017 was
something 25 or 25 and a half out of 36
so Magnus keeps breaking his record so
that that's good for him then we have as
follows Hikaru Nakamura with 23 Giri and
Wesley so are tied with 18 and a half
then ding with 18 neppo with 1736 then
Vichy with 16 other 36 Hari Krishna
invaded with 14 out of 36 and 11 did not
have the greatest tournament he was just
out of form here with 13 out of 36 in
last place and also I said that I would
prepare the Alive ratings after the
tournament so here it is so these are
the changes in the rapid here we have
them Magnus reclaims his place as the
number one rated player in the world
rapid rated player in the world he
overtakes maxime beaugeois graph
highest rated up until now and then you
have it Nakamura who dink lost 28 points
so he fell a few spots and now he's in
number six we have eleven one six and a
half points and I don't think there are
any other big differences Anand still in
the top twenty regarding rapid even
though he lost six around six points
here and okay Wesley had a terrible
rapid event as you can see in spot 20 he
dropped 15 places he lost 51 rapid
rating points so those are the changes
in the rapid section these are from at
2700 chess they always really quickly
upload you know all of all of the
differences so that's regarding rapid
and this is regarding blitz there we
have it Nakamura still the highest-rated
blitz player in the world Magnus won 36
points in the Blitz section but Nakamura
also won 14 so he still is the highest
rated so Nakamura first crossing second
the kurakin is still third highest rated
in the world you can see that being lost
ten points so he dropped two spots nepo
lost four points Wesley he was 51 points
in rapid but he won't 55 points in blitz
so he climbs up the spot six and we can
see Ireland lost six points in blitz as
well but he's still 11 which is
incredible Anand you know pushing 50
he's the in basically in the top 10
blitz players in the world but you know
not all that unbelievable he was known
as the Lightning kid at one point Gary
winning 30 blitz point lock Wong Liam
winning 88 points but not not in this
event and with it also improved he won
twelve point four points he climbed up
to two places so now he's also in the
top twenty ablates players in the world
so that's pretty much it what we
prepared for this tournament in the game
so basically it was a short
saga but with such incredible scores in
both rapid and blitz there was no other
choice but to show his game so tomorrow
we're gonna pick up on all the other
games that we didn't show as I'm sure
there were some other very nice games
all that we have requested suggested
some games so we're gonna cover those
tomorrow as much as we can before we
continue on in doing something else so
once again that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and this short coverage of
this tournament I would like to thank
Steven green again and David Compton for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon with a few more games from this
event not by Magnus checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and of course
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day